bonsoir robert rochefort
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député européen membre du groupe modem
u10 au parlement et membre du groupe de
travail contre l'interférence de
l'industrie du tabac qu'elles sont tout
d'abord les méthodes qu'emploient les
lobbyistes du tabac auprès des
parlementaires
vous savez elles sont terribles on le
sait bien il ya eu il ya d'ailleurs eu
des films aux états unis en europe donc
c'est évidemment toutes les méthodes du
lobbying
ça va de ducept comment dire de d'aller
voir les députés sans que ceux-ci
forcément déclarent qu'ils les ont vues
des cadeaux des invitations des choses
diverses et variées ça c'est à la limite
peut-être le petit détail qui est
insupportable mais sinon ça va aussi ont
des manipulations d'informations dans
des dépressions savez l'industrie du
tabac possède des centaines et des
centaines d'experts lors je vous donne
un exemple quand nous luttons contre le
trafic illégal de cigarettes est ce
qu'il s'agit et de malfaçons comme
souvent on veut nous le laisser croire
ou bien est ce qu'il s'agit de trafic
qui correspond à des cigarettes qui sont
fabriqués par les industriels eux mêmes
ils ont finalement ils sont les
bénéficiaires c'est pour ça par exemple
que l'eau non nous voulons une
traçabilité des cigarettes qu'ils ne
soient pas faites par les cigarettiers
eux mêmes et qui sera faite par des gens
qui sont des indépendants mais c'était
étonnant marcheurs de voir l'industrie
du tabac toujours aussi active en malgré
de nombreux textes pour pour lutter
contre le tabagisme le lobbying se se
moque si on peut dire de la législation
anti tabac mais vous savez c'est
peut-être l'un des lobbyings les plus
puissants de la planète parce que ça a
commencé il ya des dizaines d'années à
l'époque où on ne savait peut-être pas
autant qu'aujourd'hui que le tabac était
nocif
et puis après avoir gagné tout le monde
occidental et puis être un peu en
conflit avec un certain nombre
d'autorités dans le monde occidental
c'est l'industriel maintenant s'attaque
aux pays du sud où ils émergent et il ya
même quelque chose sur lequel nous
voulons insister c'est que beaucoup de
politiques publiques ont insisté sur la
une sorte de
comment dire de prévention sur le
consommateur une culpabilité du
consommateur avec tous ces affichages
sur le tabac qui tue et d'une certaine
façon je crois qu'il faut passer une
étape supplémentaire c'est maintenant
des industriels qu'il faut viser et pas
simplement les consommateurs sont des
messages d'ailleurs puis par les jeunes
sont souvent pris au second degré sur
pas pris pour ce qu'ils sont robert
rochefort en un tout petit mot que
peuvent 15 députés européens sas à la
puissance de ce lobbying vous nous avez
décrite quelles sont vos priorités
ils peuvent par exemple imposer une non
fuite fiscale des bénéfices de ces
grands groupes puisqu'il ya une
optimisation fiscale comme on dit ils
peuvent tout à fait imposer une taxe
pollueur payeur tous les mégots qui sont
jetés partout ça peut très bien aboutir
à une taxe qui sinon ce fonds contre le
tabagisme